there are new concerns that Japan's
medical system could collapse following
a sharp rise in the number of
coronavirus cases they're one third of
the 10,000 cases are in Tokyo
this comes as China reports at least two
dozen new cases raising concerns about a
second wave running through the global
epicenter of the virus in China there
are now at least 2.2 million known
infections around the world resulting in
at least a hundred and fifty-four
thousand deaths and that is putting the
renewed pressure on the medical
community to develop a vaccine MTS taya
is in London with this story MTS good
morning Jeff good morning well as the
coronavirus death toll continues to rise
rapidly across the world so too does the
race for a vaccine here in the UK look
no further than Oxford where British
scientists say they'll have one
available as early as September sadly of
those hospitalized with the virus 14,000
576 have now died that is an increase of
847 fatalities since yesterday it's
become a grim daily reminder Britain is
still in the depths of its coronavirus
crisis but at Friday's briefing senior
government officials had more I can
announce today that the government has
set up a vaccines task force the British
government is giving the green light and
over 17 million dollars to nearly two
dozen vaccine research projects across
the UK but one project in Oxford is so
confident that their work will prove
successful they're promising to have a
vaccine ready and manufactured by
September honestly we were following the
progress of the outbreak and as the
outbreaks spread our plans for the
project grew most projections estimate
that a vaccine will be available by the
spring of next year at the earliest
which is why antibody testing also
continues to be a top priority but the
World Health Organization is urging
caution they say the science behind the
blood tests isn't clear right now we
have no evidence that the use of a
serologic test--
can show that an individual is immune or
is protected from reinfection still
there are other glimmers
of hope Germany says it's coronavirus
outbreak is now under control
which means there are more people
recovering from the illness than there
are getting sick after the country
imposed a strict month-long lockdown now
back here in Britain the battle against
the virus remains intense with personal
protection equipment running so low
there are some concerns that hospitals
will run out as early as this weekend
Dana MT has something people here in the
United States know all about thank you